Speaker 1: How did Tucker Carlson respond to
the failure yesterday by Republicans to select
a speaker of the House? How did Sean HANNITY react
to that very same failure? Well, let's take a
look. Tucker Carlson weighed in last night and his
suggestion was McCarthy is not really conservative
anyway, maybe suggesting he's not really the
right guy for the job. Let's take a listen.
Speaker 2: McCarthy is not conservative.
Speaker 1: Enough to represent a party.
Speaker 2: That's just taking back the
House from Nancy Pelosi. And they are
definitely right about that.
Speaker 1: McCarthy is not
especially conservative. He is,
in fact, ideologically agnostic.
Speaker 2: He's flexible.
Speaker 1: His real constituency
is the lobbying community in Washington. Now,
Tucker Carlson is not wrong, but he also is wrong,
as is often the case with people like Tucker
Carlson. It's absolutely true that when I think
of Kevin McCarthy, I don't think small government
conservative who cherishes and prioritizes and
puts on a pedestal the values that we would think
of 30 years ago of Republican conservatism. He's
nothing like Reagan, for example. And believe
me, I don't agree with any of those ideas,
but he's not even in that mold. McCarthy is a
scheming opportunist with delusions of grandeur
and a sick addiction to being adjacent to power.
That's what I think of when I think of McCarthy,
and that's the way he operated during the
Trump administration until it became untenable.
And that's the way that he is operating
now. So in that sense, Tucker is correct.
On the other hand, it's also not really true that
he is the epitome of the I'll just do whatever the
lobbyists want me to do. I mean, to some degree
that's true. But in the sense that it's true of
most of the members of Congress, he is a guy
who saw an opportunity here to maybe slide in
to be speaker of the House. It may work at the
end of the day, but it's going to depend on the
direction of this group of 15 to 20 and McCarthy
ites in the Republican Party, which we will see.
So a little bit Tucker is right, but he's also
misstating the big picture of Kevin McCarthy,
which is he's just thirsty for power and wants
to be adjacent to whoever is most powerful at the
time. That's what got him to sort of go with Trump
for a while until he got caught making anti-Trump
comments. Then we go to HANNITY. HANNITY straight
up says Republicans are about to make themselves
a total clown show. Listen to this new.
Speaker 2: Year with a Fox News alert.
It is day one of the 188 Congress and House
Republicans now are on the verge of becoming
a total clown show. Careful. But despite the
cheering and elation from Democrats and the mob
in the media, it's not a dire situation yet.
Speaker 1: Yeah, so HANNITY isn't necessarily
abandoning McCarthy, but he is sounding the alarm
and he's done this before. Remember sounding the
alarm that this might end up with Republicans
looking really stupid or I guess more stupid
than they already do. Hannity's instinct
is protecting the image of the Republican
Party. And you might remember that in the
text messages that we obtained from HANNITY
in the immediate aftermath and
as the Trump riots were going on,
he recognized the way that it looked. He
recognized how terrible, terrible, terrible,
terrible. It looked for Republicans and for
Trump. What was going on on January 6th. And
he was texting, I think it was Meadows and maybe
Kaylee magnani and some others. And he certainly
had a more or less on this planet assessment of
how terrible it looked. And aside from whether
he likes Kevin McCarthy or not, and I think he's
probably fine with McCarthy one way or the other,
he is saying this could end up making us look
really, really bad. Let's see what happens today.
By the time you listen to today's show, we may
know who the speaker is or it may go another day,
which would be truly incredible. We'll follow up.
Jorge Santos may be one of the biggest liars in
the 2024 2023 Republic. Did I say 2020? I'm now
thinking I might have earlier in the show said it
was 2024. Did I do that? I don't know why. I just
had a flashback. 2023 Congress that is now taking
power. Jorge Santos had a really wacky, wacky
day yesterday on Capitol Hill. As a reminder,